visit the c-span in the classroom
website in chairman of the Fed Robert
Bremner writes about William Martin the
longest-serving chairman of the Federal
Reserve and his relationships with
presidents Truman Eisenhower Kennedy and
Johnson this discussion from politics
and prose bookstore in Washington DC
last about an hour I just want to say
that I consider this location hallowed
ground there are a lot of bookstores
that take care of general-purpose
authors and introduce them to the
general reading public there are very
few that take upon themselves the job of
trying to introduce serious writers of
nonfiction or writers of serious
nonfiction and this is one of those very
few places and I just want to thank them
on behalf of all the authors for whom
this is such an important location the
subject of my biography William
McChesney Martin is still as Barbara
said still the longest-serving chairman
of the Federal Reserve System in the man
who in the late 1950s and 60s created
Alan Greenspan's job the subtitle of the
book is the creation of the modern
American financial system and Martin did
this by reforming the New York Stock
Exchange and overhauling the Federal
Reserve System two of the pillars of the
American financial system these two
institutions still reflect the qualities
that he implanted I believe Martin's
warrant life is worth studying today for
two reasons one is to understand how the
current Federal Reserve System came to
be what it is and secondly how to
understand the current financial reform
movement that's going on in the
financial industry and Martin's
philosophy about financial regulation
I'm going to start in the middle of
Martin's life to taking you back to 1950
when the Fed had been fighting bitterly
and openly with the Treasury Department
for four years in order to terminate a
system of controls over interest rates
that were established at the end of
world
World War two the Fed wanted to return
to market-based rates in order to
restore its ability to control credit
and to deal with the inflation that was
infecting the post-war economy President
Harry Truman and his secretary of the
Treasury John Schneider were absolutely
opposed to any increase in rates former
Fed Chairman Marriner Eccles one of
Martin's predecessors had lost his
Chairman over this dispute and his
successor Tom McCabe was in the process
of losing his by early 1951 the struggle
had escalated into a highly public
crisis involving emergency meetings in
the White House leaked memorandum and
collapsed negotiations one of Treasury
secretary Snyder's closest advisors was
the number three person in his
department Bill Martin Martin persuaded
Snyder to allow him to carry out what
Martin called technical discussions with
a group from the Fed and while Snyder in
Fed chairman McCabe kampala continued to
Duke it out in public their two
assistants quietly negotiated a series
of mutual undertakings called the Accord
to resolve the situation
the genius absolute genius of the Accord
was that it described the feds primary
responsibility which is controlling our
credit as equal in importance to the
Treasury's primary responsibility which
is financing the government when these
responsibilities came into conflict the
Accord committed both parties as equals
to negotiate compromise solutions
neither truman nor schneider really
believed in the Accord but they
grudgingly went along with it
because their preferred solution a
cumbersome interagency board of appeals
was soundly rejected by both
organizations there was a typical Bill
Martin solution men of goodwill would
sit down together to negotiate their
differences in the light of the public
interest the Accord was completed Fed
Chairman mccabe resigned John Schneider
proposed his assistant
is the successor and Truman still highly
uncertain about Martin's allegiance but
willing to give another Missouri and a
chance agreed to it so Bill Martin age
45 with no commercial or central banking
experiences to run the Fed under the
terms of an accord which is
controversial not supported by the
administration purposely vague and based
on completely unproven assumptions now I
want you to envision the Fed that Martin
came in to in 1951 the Fed was seen in
the government is a third-rate agency
kind of like the office of the
controller of the currency today whoever
heard of it it had no public identity
and it will operate it under the thumb
of the Treasury for the preceding nine
years the interest rate controls had
been effectively eliminated I mean the
interest rate controls effectively
eliminated the Fed's monetary policy the
feds most important tool for influencing
credit in the economy worse yet the
overall effectiveness of monetary policy
the Fed stool was very much in doubt
both in the administration and among
economists in general one of the
elements that made the Fed unique in the
history of banking central banking is
its independence from political
persuasion but that independence had
been untested for decades both Marriner
Eccles and Thom McCabe Martin's two
predecessors has been defeated roundly
when they tried to exercise independence
from the administration and in addition
while the conquer the Fed was a creature
of the Congress it had few champions the
Banking Act of 1935 centralized monetary
policymaking in the FOMC the Federal
Open Market Committee located here at
the board headquarters in Washington DC
however Alan sprawl the powerful
president of the Federal Reserve Bank of
New York one of the 12 regional Reserve
Bank's that comprise the Federal Reserve
System actually ran the modest monetary
see the Fed was allowed to do out of his
New York offices relationships with the
commercial banking industry the industry
that the Fed regulated had soured badly
under Echols and McCabe was unable to
make any improvement whatsoever it would
be a true understatement to say that the
Fed had been magic understatement to say
that the Fed had been marginalized by
these various developments I've told you
that Martin had no prior experience as a
central banker however he did have an
unusual amount of very useful experience
that would enable him to rebuild the Fed
from the top to the bottom first he had
a remarkably strong sense of personal
values he came from a close and deeply
religious family that preached and
practiced the biblical admonitions when
his two teenage sons began to argue at
the table dinner table Martin's father
required that in the future they could
only disagree by beginning sir I
perceive you are in error and then
laying out their harkaman as best they
could if one son was particularly
desperate he could resort to sir I
perceive you are in gross error and then
try the best he could so Martin who had
a very strong temper when he was a young
man learned very early on that
self-control was crucial second Martin
was steeped in the history of the fed
his father was the founding chairman of
the st. Louis Fed in 1914 he his father
served as a living model for
courageously opposing vested interests
building support for the fledgling
Federal Reserve System and it's very
beginning third Martin really understood
the financial markets and the difficulty
of regulating them he spent eight years
on the floor of the New York Stock
Exchange during the freewheeling years
of the market manipulators of the late
1920s in the early 1930s
Martin was elected New York Stock
Exchange president when he was only 31
as part of a reform movement that took
over the exchange following the
conviction of Richard Whitney leader of
the
anti-reform old guard and former
president of the exchange who had
embezzled millions from including the
widows and orphans funds of the new york
stock exchange was a guy without many
scruples once he was in office
Martin was squeezed between the New Deal
reformer and SEC chairman William O
Douglas a reformer very much in the mode
of Eliot Spitzer today very forceful in
the old guard who still can try
controlled Martin's member membership
Martin negotiated a compromise reform
program the Douglas accepted only
because to pursue greater reform would
require the SEC to effectively take over
the exchange in 2003 the securities of
the SEC also forced out exchanged CEO
dick Grasso before it could start the
current reforms going on at the New York
Stock Exchange so things haven't changed
despite depending on a weak coalition of
moderates and reformers and in the face
of dedicated resistance by the old guard
martin eventually implemented his reform
program i should mention that in 1941
after three embattled years as president
martin was drafted into the army as a
private and is highly unusual decision
to accept the draft rather than seek
appointment as an officer moved general
Hersey who was in charge of the draft to
say to convince people that were dealing
off the top of the deck that is
selecting draftees fairly it helps to
have some of the aces and kings come off
as well as the twos and threes another
quality that martin brought to the fed
was that he'd already overhauled one
federal agency martin was appointed
president of the u.s. export-import bank
the governance export financing agency
in 1946 the government had dramatically
expanded Exxon's resources but it wanted
to use it as a piggy bank for grants to
fund post-war recovery of its political
friends notably the corrupt nationalist
Chinese government of Chiang kai-shek to
stop that loan 42 year old bill Martin
had to face down General George C
Marshall at the time
no mean feat Martin took a different
tack as CEO he pursued ex-im's
legislative mandate for creditworthy
lending and created a businesslike
financing institution that made loans
that would be paid back defending his
policies against state and Treasury took
him into the White House and that's
where Martin succeeded in persuading
Harry Truman to support his plans v
Martin had a well developed philosophy
for regulating the financial markets he
believed that regulators must understand
the business and economic realities of
the financial markets he believed they
must exercise great care in setting
rules that could undermine the
functioning of free market forces he
believed that innovation is the
lifeblood of the financial markets and
that regulation must evolve with it
regulatory rules must be as clear as
possible deal with the tough issues and
be rigorously but fairly enforced
technology should be used to monitor the
markets and finally he believed that
legislation is not effective in
regulating financial markets on a
continuing basis only capable and
flexible regulatory agencies are today
that would be the difference between
relying too much on the sarbanes-oxley
legislation and not enough on a capable
SEC now the question is what steps did
Martin take to create this modern Fed
two of his most significant rules moves
were to democratize the monetary
policymaking process
and second to strengthen the Treasury
bond market by restricting the feds
intervention he described his approach
to democratizing in typical fashion I
knew I wasn't the smartest kid on the
block but here I was so I just had to go
around where everyone expressed their
opinion and I just sum things up through
the years Martin became a master at
summing up some very heated differences
with the deceptive introduction I
believe we're all in basic agreement
here the staff was continually amazed
that individual board members accepted
Martin's summation despite their strong
differences with him a former FOMC
secretary told me that Martin
one the members support quote because
they trusted bill and they knew he
wanted to do the right thing end quote
Martin's ability to generate trust by
his honesty forthrightness and coupled
with modesty and unfailing good humor
won over his opponents throughout his
career to strengthen the treasury bond
market Martin persuaded the FOMC that
its frequent interventions in the market
up to that point
drove investors over to the sidelines
because those investors feared
considerable losses if they misjudged
what the Fed was going to do Martin
wanted a more freely functioning bond
market that was less dependent on the
actions of the Fed and more able to
accommodate what was going on in the
market through the actions of investors
Martin decided that the FM FOMC would no
longer intervene proactively to relieve
stress in the market but it would adopt
a more reactive posture waiting to
intervene until it became apparent that
normal trading activity was not able to
deal with the forces of destabilization
that those Treasury and bond and Bill
markets today are the most liquid the
most efficient in the largest securities
markets in the world
Martin's move brought him into sharp
conflict with Alan Sproul sprawl was the
president of the New York Reserve Bank
he was the best known and most skilled
central banker in the United States he
was the star of the feds traditional
meritocracy system and he occupied the
historic leadership role of the Federal
Reserve Bank of New York he had Abele
defended the Fed before Congress during
the debates over fixed rates he believed
that monetary policy should be made in
New York near the financial markets and
far away from the political interference
and in Washington he believed and
continued Fed to intervention in the
bond markets and had practiced it for a
decade Sproul actively opposed every one
of Martin's early initiatives Sproul and
Martin overlapped for five years and the
two debated continuously about many
fundamental aspects of the way the fund
should run
even though their disagreements were
often heated they remain civil to one
another and to his great credit Sproul
did not engage in divisive politicking
for his positions Martin's debates with
brass prow often produced better
decisions but in the long run sprawls
resistance to so many of Martin's
initiatives in particularly to
democratizing the Finiti decision-making
process cost him his support on the FOMC
under his retirement Sproul Riley
observed about Martin Bill was very easy
to agree with and very difficult to
disagree with Martin's coming about
sprawl was no one if the Fed should be
indispensable Martin could be tough when
it was necessary Martin's leadership
experience and free-market instincts led
him to his early policy decisions but he
wasn't an economist and he had no
experience in monetary policy
fortunately he inherited an unusually
talented staff of staff economist who
provided him with the theoretical
framework that he needed
Martin introduced new policy priorities
he assigned the feds highest priority to
fighting inflation and secondly
establishing a fully flexible monetary
policy under the title of quote leaning
against the winds of inflation whichever
way they are blowing inflation or
deflation martin believed that stable
prices promoted economic growth and the
early control of installation area
pressors limited the build-up of an
economic boom and the bust that
inevitably followed his own
grandfather's green storage business had
been bankrupted in the financial crisis
of 1893 and his father was broken by the
experience his grandfather he continued
to live in his son's home Martin's
father and Martin had that reminder for
a long time in his young life partner
Martin's arrival the feds commitment to
fighting inflation had waxed and waned
but Martin made price stability his
primary goal throughout his chairmanship
Martin believed that the Fed was too
secretive his first step is New York
Stock Exchange President had been to
rebuild investor trust by using his own
interview
with the press to get out the positive
story of reform it's easy to imagine a
clean-cut youthful looking 31 year old
as a symbol of a new day at the exchange
and despite his innate shyness Martin
made himself available for these
interviews to persuade the Fed
organization toward more openness he
referred continually to a 1923 statement
that Fed policy was easier to implement
when the public understood the feds
goals Fed wanted Martin one of the Fed
and to make sure the financial under
markets understood what the Fed intended
to do he believed in modest incremental
policy changes interest rate increases
that were well telegraphic just like
those going on now the Fed and the press
are conditioning all of us to higher
interest rates which are coming here and
coming more he encouraged federal
leaders usually Alan sprout to explain
the feds position to the financial
community and he kept but he carefully
monitored what was being said and took
much of the communication role on
himself as Alan Greenspan does today
Martin tried to keep the Congress
informed but this was no easier in 1950
than it is today
representative Wright Patman a die-hard
populist
financial applauded financial populist
from rural Texas held a series of
influential financial committee
chairmanships during Martin's term he
was a fierce Fred critic held a suit and
had a special passion for criticizing
Martin regularly calculating the cost of
a rise in interest rates on the total US
economy and telling Martin that he was
the quote most expensive public servant
the history had ever known
end quote Martin was committed to
appearing personally to defend the Fed
at congressional hearings in a typical
response Martin would admit monetary
policies are a matter of judgment we can
always do better to get congressmen to
understand the Fed position Martin used
folksy images to get his messages across
and he became forum famous for his
description of the Fed it's our job to
take away the punchbowl just
is the party really gets going Martin
was committed to reestablishing a strong
regional bank system and estimated that
he spent one third of his time on system
issues he took a strong issue interest
in selecting capable presidents for
reserve banks he encouraged the banks to
expand their capacity for economic
research and many of the leading
economists in the private and public
sectors got their initial experience at
one of the reserve banks most
importantly he revitalized the concept
of the feds independence by his actions
over his long chairmanship first he had
to live into the Accords concept of the
Fed and Treasury as equals
his crucial judgment that the bond
market would respond positively to the
end of the Federal Federal Reserve
Treasury struggle in 1951 and that
interest rates would not increase
significantly after Controls ended
proved correct this success allowed the
Fed to complete the return to
market-based rates and moderate but
certainly did not eliminate the
antagonism of Harry Truman and John
Schneider Martin told a story about
Truman's feelings by describing a chance
encounter that he had with the president
at the end of the president's term on
Park Avenue in New York City Martin
greeted the president Wow mr. president
good to see you and Martin Truman turned
around and gave him one-word response
traitor was all he said so Martin
managed to stay under the radar and
still make the changes independence
cannot be achieved however without
taking a stand for that principle an
early example occurred with Treasury
secretary George Humphrey in 1956 in the
heat of a presidential reelection
campaign
Humphrey a blunt corporate CEO and the
most powerful member of the Eisenhower
cabinet told Martin that the
administration wanted lower interest
rates to stimulate the economy and if he
had any intention to continue leading
the Fed in opposition to the will of the
president he should just resign Martin
who had worked for four years to
establish a solid working relationship
with Eisenhower could
we hope that his effort had been
effective he replied if I am violently
opposed by the administration I will
resign again Martin's judgment proved
correct Eisenhower did not support
Humphrey and pardon and the
administration backed off from that
point on Martin was always confident no
matter how difficult and how strong the
differences were that he could maintain
an effective relationship with the
President and with the administration
throughout the remaining 13 years of his
term he never used the threat of
resignation when he was disagreeing with
the administration at other times martin
exercised the feds independence in ways
that were more tactful and persistent
than confrontational as he did with John
Kennedy Kennedy had won the election in
1960 in good part by criticizing
Eisenhower and in the Fed for stopped
what he called stop-and-go economics it
was well known that Kennedy did not
approve of the feds policies under
Martin and for his part Martin was
deeply concerned about the
administration's commitment to faster
economic growth without any concern
about the inflationary implications
after a rocky start but they included a
very public spat Martin found that he
could not only work with Kennedy but
also he could disagree with him
nevertheless when his four-year
chairmanship term was up in 1963 Martin
still expected to be replaced
Kennedy surprised him totally by asking
him to stay on saying quote I know you
don't always agree with what we're doing
and my people don't always like what
you're doing but in our dealings I found
you to be independent minded and willing
to speak up for your position there are
too few such people and they are what a
president needs after all above all
finally there are times when
independence must be exercised in a
confrontational setting though Martin
and Lyndon Johnson engaged in a
four-year struggle over the Johnson
administration's failure to deal with
the growing government death
since in the build-up of inflationary
pressures it included was a well
telegraphed decision to raise the feds
discount rate in 1965 the first increase
in almost 5 years and it was taken in
face of enormous opposition by the
administration martin warned the board
that a vote to raise rates would show
the world that the Fed did not yield to
administration pressure but that their
decision could quote result in an
important revamping of the Federal
Reserve System end quote by an angry and
powerful president in a classic
confrontation with Johnson after the
vote Martin defined his move using a
very carefully circumscribed view of the
feds independence and I have to quote
from the book the meeting took place in
Johnson's simple office at the LBJ Ranch
it was a classic confrontation to
determine men both of whom believed that
the goals for which they had worked all
their lives were at stake
Johnson wasted no time before he went on
the attack you've got me in a position
where you can run a rapier into me and
you've done it Johnson accused Martin of
placing himself above the presidency and
totally disregarding his wishes you went
ahead and did something that I
disapproved of it can affect my entire
term here he finished you took advantage
of me and and I want you to know that
that's a despicable thing to do as he so
often did six foot four inch Lyndon
Johnson had personalized the issue and
brought the full force of his physical
and presidential presence to bear on his
adversary Martin admitted later that he
was shaken but determined stick to his
position and not to insult the President
of the United States in his quiet but
determined way Martin fought back
mr. president we were not precipitous
about this I warned you about it we
discussed this and you asked me to delay
it but we can't wait any longer and
another point Martin tried to reduce any
possible threat to John's presidency
by saying now you're the president and
I'm just a worker in the vineyard way
down the line I have no constituency I
have a board that supports me sometimes
and sometimes it doesn't in this they
supported me but only by a four to three
vote finally Martin said I've never
implied that I'm right and you're wrong
but I have a very strong conviction that
the Federal Reserve Act placed the
responsibility for interest rates with
the Federal Reserve Board this is one of
those few occasions where the Federal
Reserve Board decision has to be final
fortunately from Larten Johnson had
often used the separation of powers act
as the Senate Majority Leader when he
had to differ with an administration and
Johnson recognized Martin's position
another of Martin's conditions major
contributions was to establish the Fed
Chairman as the personification of the
feds reputation for nonpartisan
competence and its commitment to working
with the administration in the nation's
interest this is certainly symbolized by
Alan Greenspan today Martin was the
first German to be reappointed by
presidents from both parties he wrecked
Lee man Martin regularly acknowledged
that the administration had the
responsibility for settings the nation's
economic goals and for implementing them
through budgetary policy and he felt
that the Fed should cooperate with the
administration's priorities unless the
Fed felt that it justified jeopardized
the prospects for steady economic growth
and stable prices
the feds cooperation with the Treasury
Department led to the restoration of
market-based interest rates during the
Truman administration similarly its
cooperation with the Eisenhower
administration ended the inflation that
had inflicted the US economy off and on
since the end of World War two when the
Johnson administration chose to ignore a
rapidly overheating economy and rising
inflationary pressures martin said
martin abandoned his posture of
cooperation the credit tightening
initiated in 1965 despite the opposition
of the administration crushed home
building
and it threatened to liquidate the
Savings and Loan industry before the
FOMC decided that it simply couldn't go
any further one of Martin's strongest
beliefs was that monetary policy had
inherent limitations and that it was
most effective when it was working in
concert with the government's fiscal
policy martin pleaded with the
administration for a tax increase to
complement monetary policy but the
administration stonewalled it martin
believed that it was a feds Chairman's
job to speak out on the principles of
financial and fiscal responsibility
whether they involved individual
americans or the administration and
whether they wanted to hear it or not
martin recognized that these public
lectures often made him sound like
cassandra and he occasionally lampooned
himself with statements like arizona
Artin complaining again but he's always
doing that in the end neither monetary
policy nor the tax increase were
sufficient to slow down the inflation
and it took another 14 years to bring it
under control it raises the question why
wasn't Martin who devoted himself to
fighting inflation more effective in
dealing with what became known as the
great inflation there are a number of
reasons which together help to cover
answer most of that question but not all
some will never be answered one was that
in 1967 in 1968 most of the economists
at the Fed and in the population at
large were Kansans who were followers of
British economist John Maynard Keynes
and they believed that a certain amount
of inflation was the price of sustained
economic growth
Martin was skeptical of this conclusion
but he could not sustain a sufficiently
strong majority on the FOMC to retain
his tightening and he did truly lead by
consensus another reason that was that
in 1969 the general population had
almost no experience with inflation in
Martin's lonely anti-inflationary
campaign never generated a groundswell
of public support finally he just ran
out of time
his 14 year non-renewable term on the
board ended in January 1970 and Nixon's
choice for his successor Arthur Burns
had made it very clear that he would not
sustain the credit restraint at the Fed
however the Great Inflation is not Bill
Martin's true legacy the modern Fed is
it resides in the feds unequaled
reputation and relationship with its
sister agencies the Congress foreign
central banks and of course the
administration it resides in a strong
marketplace for Treasury securities
through which the government finances
its significant deficits and through
which the Fed operates exercises its
monetary policy it resides in the 12
Reserve banks that enjoy strong local
support among industry and banks in
their districts it resides with the Fed
history of pragmatic policymaking that
balances the eternal tension between
price stability and sustained economic
growth it resides in a regulatory
philosophy that balances the virtues of
free markets competition and innovation
with protection of the public interest
it resides in a reputation for
nonpartisan competence and a commitment
to the public industry public interest
enjoyed by the Fed and personified by
its chairman that is Bill Martin's
remarkable legacy and that's why I
titled his life story the chairman of
the Fed thank you
[Applause]
so I guess if there are any questions if
I'd answer them all then we can go on to
book signing of course but if there are
a few questions be happy to answer them
yes yes we have the tangle with the
chairman of the of the New York Federal
Reserve Board makes me realize that we
never hear about the independence of the
of the regional boards or their
directors do they actually have a role
or do they simply operate as a committee
of the whole or why don't we hear about
them that's a good question
part of the reason is because the
independent banks have things to do in
their district probably the most
important is still the chairman of the
Federal Reserve Bank of New York and
they have they are very active involved
actively involved today in the concerns
about the fragility possible fragility
of the international monetary system and
those the the role of those those
presidents is to represent the economic
priorities and concerns of their regions
the FOMC has 12 votes seven are the
governors of the Federal Reserve System
including the chairman in five are
allocated among the twelve presidents on
a rotating basis so it's very hard for
our Chairman who operates on a consensus
as Alan Greenspan does and is Bill
Martin did very hard for them to
maintain a consensus if they aren't able
to get a majority of the Reserve Bank's
so so the it's it's really a collective
contribution that those individual
presidents make but the person who's in
New York has a unique responsibility for
overseeing the financial system since
they're so close to it hope that answers
the question yes a general question
about interest rates we hear of lots of
knobs that can be turned when you read
Barron's may
or some of the other things money supply
m1 m2 m3 dot dot dot M sub n is the is
is the fact that interest rates is what
the popular press focuses on really the
only thing that that the guy can turn or
can he truly turn money supply and in
which of the fed guys had their ways of
their strategies of turning the knobs
that control our economy well it's there
are a lot of ingredients to interest
rates as they work through the economy
the Fed has probably the control over
the most visible rate which is its
discount rate which is tied very closely
to short-term money rates now but the
banking system is much more I should say
the financial system is much more
complicated than it used to be in that
credit is provided by non commercial
banks so that there are other ways for
the borrowers of the system to get
credit and the Fed oftentimes has only
marginal or no impact on those sources
of credit
the only chairman who really was able to
make a singular impact on the money
supply was Paul Volcker who used the
approach of controlling the money supply
in the 70s to bring the end to the great
inflation that we were talking about but
during that time interest rates rain
went as high short-term rates as high as
22 percent those of us with gray hair
can remember that those were very
frightening days but in fact that was
what it took to bring the inflation
under control and even today the
importance of that rate as it spreads
through the economy is more visible the
bank the Federal Reserve System has a
more subtle but in somewhat less less
blanket but a more subtle influence on
the money supply in terms of the bank
reserves it provides reserves to the
banking system and it does that through
the open market operations in New York
and that way they can either force banks
to begin to restrict
lending or make their reserves more
ample and to encourage their lending and
they do that on a counter or cyclical
basis so so that's less visible but it's
equally important and it's a it's a more
subtle it's a fine-tuning kind of thing
that goes on on a daily and weekly basis
I does that answer your question yeah
yes it's sheds are dead much traditional
light I don't know if there's not a big
line of questions I'd like to pursue
that line of thought one more step okay
one more step but then one more step
another number that comes out is the
time it takes to clear all the time
delay has also recently been put in I
could have met and it used to take and I
don't know if I wasn't following who was
chairman of the Fed when I first got my
first checking account but when I cashed
a check it used to take as much as two
weeks before that check would reach my
account if it was an out-of-state bank
and now it it reaches the it reaches it
the same day in a lot of cases well I'll
tell you what rather than pursue that
very far let me simply say that we've
drifted a little way from from Bill
Martin except that I can tell you that
the Fed is certainly getting on board
with the last changes to necessitate a
complete electronic transfer so that
even now we're talking about three days
and then it'll be down to a day and
probably when people stop using cheques
that'll be instantaneous as so many of
the other parts of the financial system
are so so it's coming you know even
better thank you
you opened a lot of interesting
portals for me and there even in a
cursory reading of your book well thank
you
well I think one night yes I was
wondering if you could compare Martin's
philosophy with Alan Greenspan's and I
guess I'm not sure if is in the 70s of
the 80s of the Keynesian philosophy was
sort of felt all fell away I suppose
that the current philosophy is more in
line with Martin's philosophy but and
then if would you comment do other
countries other market economies have
this Federal Reserve and is it if they
do I don't know if you know this is part
of your purview and if they do is that
law is it independent like ours and how
critical is that to an economy to have
this federal independent Federal Reserve
right well you asked a number of
questions I'll start with the last and
that I can remember and that is that the
as I mentioned that the feds unique
contribution is its independence from
political it's it's almost complete
independence from political influence
the Federal Reserve System is actually a
private public partnership the stock of
the Federal Reserve System is held by
the commercial banking industry they
can't get dividends they can't do it
exercise it but nevertheless they do own
it so that there is a unique
relationship between the private sector
and the public sector in our central
bank which is not true of any other
central bank the European Central Bank's
have generally become much more
independent in the last ten years
historically they were pretty much
operating under the thumb of the
government the British the Central Bank
of England has always been the most the
first most institutionalized most
well-regarded developed most of the
concepts in the beginning but then this
this experiment which is almost 100
years old in the United States it's
truly a remarkable development and has
many unique characteristics and that's
why it plays the role that it does in
addition it's in such an important
economy to try to remember the second
part which was comparing Alan Greenspan
and Bill Martin which is a bit of a
trick there
I'm convinced that there are many more
similarities than there are differences
in that both are pragmatists both try to
influence behind-the-scenes the
government in terms of its fiscal
policies both are very committed to free
markets open markets and regulation that
accepts the importance of open market
behavior they there are there is one
significant difference and that is that
as I mentioned Martin felt a a strong
responsibility to carry the nation's
responsibilities for for fiscal and
financial responsibility and make that a
public campaign and keep that issue
before the public now I do believe that
it's possible to conclude that that
Martin might have been out on the on the
public platform with his concerns about
the deficits and the concern about the
implications of those for Social
Security and Medicare perhaps earlier
than chairman Greenspan yeah but I think
they probably agree on that and honestly
I think that was probably more going on
behind the scenes because that's both of
these men are very skilled at working
within an administration behind the
scenes because that's where they feel
they can be most effective no no I think
it was that okay good evening
um I have a quick clarification than a
question um is uh is it true that the
Federal Reserve has responsibility both
equally to have control interest rates
and have full employment by statute of
Congress is that a true statement I know
there is not an obligation on the feds
part to produce full employment there's
not there the employment acts that
humphrey-hawkins the Employment Act of
1946 make full employment and goal but
it does not make the feds responsibility
for filling that you maybe highlight
some of mr. Martin's conflict between
those two goals with regards to his job
well one of the the most sensitive
aspects of the Federal Reserve is
appearing to be indifferent to
unemployment that is is a almost has
been a problem now Martin made the
statement that he felt that if any one
person were unemployed that that person
felt unemployment was a very important
issue and he sympathized with it I think
and and in fact he was when he was a
young man was involved in in studying
unemployment insurance programs in
various other countries he had a strong
feeling about the importance of
unemployment personally but he also had
a strong feeling about the importance of
stable economic growth and he felt in
the long term that too to put too much
emphasis on economic growth at the risk
of having the economy become
inflationary was not a service to the
people who were unemployed the
unemployment insurance that unemployment
generally during the downturns was a
temporary condition and the feds job was
to try and reduce that amount of
temporary condition as to as short a
period as possible and you did that by
expanding the the growth periods in the
economy so I but I it's a very sensitive
issue continues to be that today and
there the the administration and the Fed
often see that issue from different
points of view and your comments you you
you beautifully summarized the enormous
importance of the the human element of
the of the chairman of the Fed his his
role as a an administrator and one who
brings people together many of us can
remember as you alluded to that was
during those years that there's this
enormous debate beginning between the
Keynesian zazz as you're marked in the
Milton Friedman School in Chicago here
was a man who certainly had no
particular standing as an economist but
how did he do
with the the economic or the the
community of economists and kind of
changed the horses that he was that he
was driving while all the chariot was
moving at full speed ahead thanks for
the question
Martin Martin had during most of his
term a staff member read all of the
economic books that came out of the
theory and summarized them for him that
was one source so he really wanted to be
as aware as possible of what current
economic thought was obviously none of
the details he simply didn't have the
capacity to do that but he he wanted to
be aware as much as possible secondly he
established a an academic research board
which was an advisory board which
brought in renowned economists of
various stripes around the country to
the to the Fed on an annual basis to
talk about to try to get alternative
views as I mentioned within the Fed
during his term the Keynesian ins really
became by far the majority of his staff
of the economists who are on the FOMC
and on these governors so that the the
and actually by the time he retired the
monetarists were were still in a
relatively early stage of their public
presentations they really weren't having
the impact it was a small school out in
Chicago around Milton Friedman in a few
other places what and and in fact there
were very strong feelings anti monetary
particularly in the New York Bank and
oftentimes if a president of one of the
bank's felt very strongly about an issue
he would direct his his economic staff
to do research on that and write papers
and make statements so Martin Martin was
fortunate as I indicated when he first
came by being tutored by three legends
in fed history of economic development
of economics I will say just a couple of
things that are that are important one
is that
that during this during the sixties
economic models computer-based models of
the economy we're starting to become
much more widely accepted and and it was
used within the Fed but Martin had a
problem with using that to develop a
forecast which then became a
straitjacket for thinking about how the
Fed should respond fed Martin believed
very much in pragmatism in that you
looked at the economic conditions as
they flowed toward you and you were
constantly modifying your position in
order to accept that additional
information that you weren't looking for
the money supply to be growing in X or
for bank reserves to be growing at Y you
were trying to do Ollie's and have a
broader range as possible of indicators
and I think Alan Greenspan does that
today so it was a mix bomb I think thank
you it's a it's a it was a remarkable
achievement and again we thank you for
bringing back to our attention a man who
who who really as you say laid the whole
groundwork for an institution that we
all think of every day today thank you
you talked a lot about how important the
independence of the Fed is and how
important Martin was in establishing
that I wondered if you'd briefly address
how the problems with maintaining that
any challenges to that independence
particularly as we look toward a new
chair in the not-too-distant future I
think we have been fortunate in the last
ten years to have an economy which has
been produced a couple of soft landings
for us yeah I think that as a result of
that that the tax revenues and the
government's ability to plan its its
budgets have been less complicated than
they were certainly during Martin's time
I think that those conditions tend to
put the pressure
on a president relative to the Fed
Chairman and those pressures have been a
little less in the last decade I think
because of good economic management
because of fortunate marking market in
worldwide economic circumstances and so
I think that there had been fewer
challenges during Arthur burns time
there were a number of legislative
changes that people wanted to force some
brackets around what the Federal Reserve
could and couldn't do that came from
Congress there have been a few classic
confrontations now between a president
and in a chairman of the board but I I
suspect that most of us can't remember
the last time that's happened and I
think it's been generally because the
economic conditions have I have lessened
that the possibilities for friction for
a wonderful talk I'm gonna hold this
chair up here to sit down inside books
people will line up to my left please
and also if you'll help us fold the
chairs it's a great help
Robert Bremner is a former investment
banker and management consultant
chairman of the Fed is published by Yale
University Press online at Yale Books
calm